what other advice have you got from
billionaires sort of a Funny Story one
of the guys that is a billionaire but
also spent some time with Warren Buffett
had a story about how he went to dinner
with Warren he goes to dinner with
Warren he's like I have 400 questions
for Warren fly there and I go and sit
down for dinner and he's like I couldn't
ask him a question because he just kept
asking me questions all he did the whole
time was pick my brain on what I thought
here what I thought there and he had
basically gotten all this information
from me and I had gotten so he's met a
couple other people that know him too
and he's like the smartest richest
people I know ask the most questions and
try to prove their intelligence the
least because they know that the ones
who collect the most knowledge have the
biggest unfair advantage and so I found
that almost across the board